my name is Frank I've been alive for 35
days I didn't witness the horrors of the
Second World War where Europe tore
itself apart
while the peace that followed I wasn't
alive on the day when the first document
was signed which in European nations
closer in common purpose france's
Foreign Minister Robert Schumann is the
author of the bold imaginative plan
which bears his name they they are
seated side by side together
I didn't see the frozen border dividing
our continent or the day at peacefully
melted
I didn't witness the event of Europe
first reaching for the stars
or answering impossible questions all
the moment we are all finally free to
travel to live and work across borders
unhindered and equal in the eyes of our
shared laws
but because of all those things and all
the work that millions of men and women
who had a vision from peaceful and
prosperous group of Nations living in
harmony gained for me to be free
through your sacrifice and hope I thank
you for remembering Europe every day
he's not a movement to pockets but a
movement of people
you